And then possibly one of the most satisfying things you can do in the material editor is
to get things organized by adding comments.
So I come from a very blueprint driven background in Unreal so it's very nice that the material
editor now has this functionality to comment and give things descriptions and comment colors.
And so we can add a comment by pressing C. So let's jump into the editor again and let's
just get everything cleaned up here.
So we will drag let's say the base color into some different real estate and let's hit C
on our keyboard and let's type base color, well let's call this albedo, it makes sense
albedo.
And you'll see by default we get a little comment box above.
I generally don't like the comment box above there but you can keep it if you want.
Just sorry I got rid of that.
So when we select the comment color we want to go to maybe say TLE or turquoisey kind
of color.
I generally like dropping the alpha down to maybe a 0.4 or something like that, it just
gives it a little bit of a softer feel, kind of nice.
So we'll go to font size, if you have a big material graph maybe you have size 40 on like
some kind of key information up here but then maybe you don't need as much for say metallic
there, maybe it's even a 12 instead.
Maybe metallic is a darker color again maybe dropping that alpha down just to soften it.
You can also copy and paste these so I'm just going to select metallic, copy and let's go
roughness, let's maybe change this to a different color, you can just drag and drop that in
and as soon as you drag and drop it in then it moves it around which is really nice.
And then let's do normal and I think normal has to be blue probably, well a bluish purple.
Deep blue.
Again you could spend a lot of time trying to clean this stuff up but that's good for
now, it just shows you how to keep things organized, you can of course go out to town
on this kind of thing and yeah if you want to do anything like that you can.
The only last thing I like to do is double click on any of these wires and you can kind
of add these re-root nodes that you can also move around with your keyboard as well.
So you just double click on the wire and it just creates a nice satisfying flow of information
if you so wish, in case you've got any like tangling of wires and just keeping things
nice and organized I just like to double click, create re-root nodes and like I said move
them around on your keyboard or do that.
It just you know especially if you bring information out here just keep things nice and clean and
organized so good way to keep things tidy in your material editor.